[Music]
check this
out disregarding ocean boundaries
testing microchips the Chinese
government released a
map convincing depictions of individuals
doing or saying things that they never
did deep fakes deep fakes what is even
real Lee Harvey Oswald thing was
actually a setup I'm just a py py which
is like an old timey term for like the
Fall Guy the the one who was set up by
the leaders around him let's do this our
service members have encountered
unidentified aerial phenomena an
unidentified aerial phenomena UAP baby
we're exiting a period of incredible
growth look at this
[Music]
graph but if you have a thousand of
these switches suddenly you have
something that kind of resembles a
little brain there's actually not a ton
of nuance here but they would be in
something very
[Music]
interesting a quiet Revolution stir the
Berlin Wall has fallen oh
yeah of things
[Music]
depending and I don't understand why and
I want to understand
why all right let's do this check this
out microchips it conducts electricity
really well it is a semiconductor of
electricity in the heart of Ukraine a
quiet Revolution stirs the creation of
new tools of War built by volunteers and
students and technicians Tinkers who are
repurposing their skills to resist
Invasion and guess what this happened
the US does not currently have the the
ability to even track this weapon much
less defeat it Chinese spy balloon
drifting across North America these two
Navy Pilots arrive to the scene the Navy
report describes this object as quote an
elongated egg or a Tic Tac that was
uniformally white across the entire body
it was approximately 46 ft in length one
of the pilots with his weapons officer
in the back wanted to get a closer look
is actually just another Quirk of the
image sensors that they use in the
military on the specialzed cameras the
second biggest bank collapse in US
history the bank is called the Silicon
Dolly bank now the baker with his new
loan goes and buys his oven for $9,000
and the oven seller takes that $99,000
and goes and puts it in their Bank this
document from the US Department of
Defense this year's is more detailed
than China quote remains our most
consequential strategic competitor for
coming decades and so now you see a
competition between these two great
powers that have become deeply economic
i al entwined over the last 50 years I'm
not anti-ilk I love milk no seriously we
got we got to do this got
me looks great dude my full-time job is
to do journalism I sit around and fact
check things all day if I get something
wrong it's a cardinal sin Joseph
Smith he's someone I know well he's the
author of a worldview that I held for
most of my life nearly half of Sudan's
remaining population is in dire
humanitarian need Sudan is moving
towards a civil war let me get you up to
speed on what's Happening Here and show
you how Sudan's location here near the
suest canal in the Horn of Africa makes
it geopolitically important these
messages were spread and Amplified by
one social media platform in this
country that was just starting to use
the internet conspiracies and
incitements to violence all directed at
the country's Muslim minority are just
overrunning the platform so let me show
you how the US kept their colony in the
Caribbean using Brute Force spying and
the abuse of land and
people this is how the US stole Puerto
Rico Yugoslavia a Federation of six
countries is ripping itself apart their
economy is in ruin and they're replacing
communism with nationalism the kind that
thrives on focusing on ethnic and
religious differences forcibly punching
out a government from Power no elections
no process just power being seized but I
want to show you how the coup has been
used by the United States of America as
a tool to get what they want on the
world stage rockets and air strikes
continue to rain down on Israel and Gaza
and this is where we need to zoom out to
get a bigger picture look at the rest of
this
region how did we get this a map so
detailed to truly unveil Antarctica's
Mysteries we needed to venture inside it
[Music]
we'll talk about it tomorrow um but I
just didn't want you to stress tonight
um I wanted you to know that things
are good okay all right look at this
happy guy look at this happy guy he was
going through his own he was going
through his own little emotional roller
coaster thank you thank you ter and look
we have
[Music]
Greenland I'm at an airport in rural
Greenland it's like in this fur system
near the village of umak all of the
cameras and stuff just keep dying
because it's so damn cold it is -30° in
Greenland Greenland Greenland Greenland
Greenland should I reference Greenland I
should I be like I was I just was up
here like I I can't not be like by the
way like no there's one thing Kim Jong
ill like to do it was to talk about his
thoughts on Cinema he wrote an entire
book about it which was kind of the
impetus of this entire video this book
oh you should just put this book in
front of Johnny Johnny's walking around
and he sees it he like oh what's this
he's like we got to make a video about
this and that put an idea in the
pipeline that would eventually become my
Earth simar
video this is for the moon landing video
get through and we hired someone with an
old timey like radio Transatlantic
accent to do it instead buckle up for
this
one in a world on the brink of
Destruction we talked to astrophysicists
meteorologists and NASA historians to
better understand the moonlanding
conspiracy there's basically no chance
of getting a decent shot of the stars in
this environment former Congressman
among several people hit with Insider
training charges today their Insider
knowledge may help them make the best
bets on on Wall Street Congressman R con
from California making bank during
Financial
meltdown God no I have children and if I
ever gave them this much milk I'd feel
like a
criminal on March 13th 1962 The Joint
Chiefs of Staff put this document in
front of the secretary of defense for
approval from the president a secret
meeting and the memo It produced meant
only for the eyes of top British
officials these leaders wanted to remind
the world who the global superpower was
and they've been doing it for a long
time Russia May sabotage undee cables if
you have access to submarine cables
which governments and militaries do you
can scrape through the insulation of
this cable you can splice in another
cable and you can duplicate the signal
and hear everything your enemy is saying
these few hundred cables that connect
our world contain an unfathomable amount
of data and it would seem impossible
that any government agency would be able
to spy on it all impossible that is if
we didn't have solid proof that they do
we've been talking to Russian
journalists a lot of them independent
who have moved to YouTube to try to
escape censorship you could be swimming
in the ocean one day minding your own
business and right below you there could
literally be this massive 48,000 ton
metal machine with a couple hundred
humans aboard equipped with nuclear
warheads that could be launched at a
moment's notice what have we created I
started a new Channel with my old Vox
colleague Sam Ellis it is live now it is
called search party Rival politicians
and a new class of ultra wealthy
businessmen called oligarchs were
battling for power under a weakening
yelson according to data gathered by
ESPN between 1900 and 1989 the All
Blacks won 71% of their tests if China
begins The Invasion its missiles still
could destroy taiwan's planes and
[Music]
ships
I need to show you a video pause real
quick Henry Kissinger one of the most
controversial and Powerful figures in
American politics is dead it's unlike
any substance on Earth there's nothing
wrong with drinking olive oil this stuff
is so good yeah that Gap up here get
another bag I got to tell you something
really quick I have a slightly
complicated relationship with
breakfast
camera is just covered in
cheese in another study 92% of the
supplements that were tested by
scientists were contaminated with
bacteria no in there we've been doing
this for an hour and a half
[Music]
don't through Greenland exploring this
massive Island mostly have been in the
fs these rural communities hunting for
seals and riding on dog sleds
bet bet
[Music]
bet I'm not in touch not in touch here
in the office we actually had some
pretty nice heated debates about Joe
Rogan unbelievably insane militants who
seized an Israeli owned tanker over the
weekend were likely Somali pirates this
line represents the expansion of the
piracy industry in somaria the worst
nuclear reactor acent today today
nuclear power is in Decline and I've
been trying to understand why I ended up
in a conversation with my friend Cleo
who makes a show called huge if
[Music]
true feels
amazing okay so that's all I've got and
we will see you all next year bye
everyone
bye
[Music]
two one
by oh that worked that was
[Music]
cute we miss you bye
everyone
I was out of frame guys
really I made the music
here yeah I should have
been
godamn